[Musique]
Cyril Melchior président du Département
a reçu au palais de la source mardi 16
août le ministre de l'éducation et de la
jeunesse Gabriel Attal et la secrétaire
d'État à la Jeunesse et au service
national universel Prisca the
sujet majeurs qui concernent bien sûr la
vie des collégiens la promotion des
jeunes réunionnais et là un domaine tout
particulièrement préoccupe c'est d'abord
que l'école elle soit inclusive que le
collège puisse accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles les
jeunes qui sont en difficulté parfois
pour de handicap nous travaillons aussi
bien sûr à la réussite scolaire il faut
le dire nous avons des jeunes qui vont
vers l'excellence mais à côté de cela
nous avons aussi beaucoup de précarité
qui fait que malheureusement il y en a
qui qui sont déjà donc comment lutter
contre les échecs scolaires je salue
cette capacité de dialogue et d'écoute
de la part du gouvernement sur tous ces
sujets qui concernent la réunion qui a
un enjeu évidemment à pouvoir combler
les lacunes c'est pour ça qu'en classe
de 6e on va être le paquet sur la 6e là
avec leur supplémentaires de
renforcement et d'approfondissement en
maths et en français avec la
généralisation du défaut éthique devoir
fait pour tous les 6e pour faire les
devoirs au collège plutôt qu'à la maison
parce que tout le monde est pas
accompagné de la même manière à la
maison on souhaite pouvoir accueillir
davantage les élèves c'est-à-dire sur
une période plus longue dans la journée
et donc on va expérimenter ce 8 heures
18h ici à la Réunion au collège du
tampon c'est à dire qu'ils vont pouvoir
faire leurs devoirs au collège plutôt
qu'à la maison qui vont pouvoir être
accompagnés aussi pour la pratique
sportive pour la découverte culturelle
en orientation donc moi j'attends
beaucoup de cette expérimentation qui
aura lieu et je remercie le département
de ce joindre à nos efforts sur le sujet
pour son deuxième jour de visite Gabriel
Attal a été accueilli par Cyril Melker
au collège Bourbon à Saint-Denis le
président du conseil départemental a
rappelé que la collectivité est
partenaire du programme PHARE dispositif
national de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire décrété cause nationale par le
ministre et son arrivée à La Réunion le
département accompagne à sa façon
ces dispositif parce que je tiens à le
dire c'est l'État qui porte le sujet du
harcèlement scolaire à travers les
actions menées par le rectorat mais nous
départements nous avons des financements
qui permettent justement de financer la
parution de flyers la concrétisation au
quotidien de certaines actions le
Conseil départemental des Jeunes
réfléchit sur plusieurs thèmes dont le
harcèlement scolaire ce sujet est bien
porté prise en compte par le Conseil
départemental des jeunes
de nos principales thématiques à traiter
au CDG donc notamment le 3 juin dernier
nous avons reçu une formation pour
entrer dans le programme PHARE avec les
agents du rectorat nous avons été
sensibilisés nous avons été sensibilisés
sur le harcèlement et aussi sur les
addictions en parallèle et c'est vrai
que nous menons différentes actions donc
notamment au mois de décembre nous
allons commencer des ateliers sur les
collèges et aussi nous allons étendre
cette formation pour être ambassadeur du
harcèlement au 5e dans l'après-midi la
délégation s'est rendu cette fois-ci
dans l'Est au collège Guy Moquet à
Saint-Benoît ils ont assisté à un cours
de science de la vie et de la terre
dédiée au développement durable
donc ici c'est une classe de 6e et
l'objectif c'était vraiment de leur
faire une découverte en fait de du
compostage des biodéchets parce qu'en
fait le collège s'inscrit directement
dans dans le cadre de la loi Haget en
fait qui qui vise à trier et valoriser
tous les déchets alimentaires à partir
du 1er janvier 2024 et dans ce cadre-là
avec avec les alchimistes on va
accompagner la structure pour pouvoir
exactement donc on va accompagner la
structure pour qui trie bien et qui
compost l'ensemble des déchets
alimentaires sur place j'ai trouvé ça
très concret très ludique et en même
temps très utile parce que
pas beaucoup à l'éducation développement
durable c'est-à-dire les élèves
eux-mêmes le demandent souvent ils nous
reproche de pas être suffisamment
sensibilisé sur ces questions là dans un
cadre scolaire on a fait il y a quelques
années les échos délégués ça fonctionne
assez bien il faut continuer maintenant
d'avoir beaucoup plus dans le la
maquette pédagogique et dans le cadre
scolaire ces enseignements mais je pense
que là où c'est le mieux c'est quand
vous avez un enseignement qui permet en
plus de changer le cadre de vie de
l'établissement et là typiquement
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les élèves
tout à l'heure avec nous ils ont appris
comment fonctionner un compost et pas
juste comme ça pour le principe c'est
que le compost va être utilisé bientôt
dans le collège et on sait qu'il y a
beaucoup de d'efforts à faire aussi sur
la question du tri sélectif dans nos
établissements publics ici à la Réunion
et dans beaucoup d'autres académies donc
je pense que c'est très utile et je
soutiens cette initiative
un débat s'est ensuite déroulé avec les
membres de la cité éducative de
Saint-Benoît Gabriel Attali a annoncé
une enveloppe de 500 millions d'euros
dédiés à la rénovation du bâtis scolaire
[Musique]